the jurogan experience
robert can you explain some of the um
what you ended up finding out
was hidden from you
what was the exculpatory evidence
well uh
they would they would have that uh
first of all first of all uh
maybe i can explain the crimes right
that was a spread of crime that happened
in the french quarters in new orleans
um
it was
i think three armed robberies uh
a raping and kidnapping
and a murder was tied to that so he
they it took all these crimes and said
it was a part of a spree
all right they had a um
a card that was involved
in a crime and
they eventually
over the period well
over the
couple of weeks after the crime happened
maybe
they found out who the car
um that was involved
and
during the time when they was doing the
investigation my name came up as a as
the anonymous tip came in right
so what they what they did was they
eventually arrested me
and
connected me to the car
that was actually used in in in all
these sprees of crime including the the
the murder the robbery the kidnappings
and the rape
uh
and
years later uh
eventually found out that
another guy got arrested for the murder
uh
and was connected
he in his possession he had possessed it
jury and articles are evidence from
crime spree
and from each of the victims he had
jewelry from the woman
that was robbed he had clothing from one
of the other women
i think the woman that was raped
and they never turned this over to him
right
and so
yeah they would they would hail that
um from me that was that that how did
they connect you with the car
that's that's what i'm about to explain
they connected me the car how they
connected me with the car
uh
the
prosecutor theory
was that
like when they arrested this guy
they got him to
say that
me and him was friends
and
he allowed me to use the car
right
at times
to commit the crime but all i ever did
suggested uh
differently
and
so
at trial what they did was
they charge
he got convicted of the actual murder
right
he got convicted of murder and it
separated him from the other crimes and
it charged me with the other crimes
right
but um unbeknownst to me
uh on the day of trial that i was uh
for the rape kidnapping in the armed
robberies
that
uh
he told the prosecutor that i had
nothing to do with
none of the crimes that he i never used
a car none of that
right
but when i went to trial the prosecutor
said something totally opposite
they prosecute me on the third that
means this guy was best friend he
allowed me to use it did you know him i
didn't know him at all
never seen him a day in my life
and the short answer to your question
joe about what they had connecting him
to the car
a driver's license you would think a
driver's license a registration
insurance someone that had seen them in
the car the answer is they had
absolutely nothing they had a word they
had the word of a guy that had been
accused and tied to these murders who
was looking to put it on someone else
how did he put it on you though
he found out that there was a tip
right implicating him right
right
absolutely
and so he tried to be a snitch to get
the heat off of him and put it on you
absolutely
and they let that happen yep even though
they knew right and it goes deeper than
that uh so after i get convicted
uh
i'm still charged with the
with the murder of the british tourists
right still i'm still actually charged
with it even though i haven't been going
back and forth to court with it at this
time
after i get convicted and i know i was
going to get a life sentence for the
rape
uh the kidnapping the three armed
robbers
uh
so the district attorney
uh
made an offer to my defense attorney um
and eventually brought it to me on the
day of my sentence and said that
okay
we can give him 25 years
uh 21 years for the murder
get him a manslaughter right
and
i don't know what type of stuff that
happens out of my presence between my
attorney and district attorney but i was
scared as [ __ ] i just received a life
sentence
uh i know i was about to get sentenced
to a life for
the the rape
and 25 or whatever maybe in 99 years for
every on robbery i don't know i was
scared that [ __ ]
so i took the 21-year plea
but i never admitted to anything
right
and a part of evidence was
that
the guy
who we we we talking about that that
was initially trying to involve me he
was found guilty of the murder
already
he was already the final guilty so they
were trying you for a crime they already
had convicted someone for absolutely how
is that possible it happened
because that what they're trying to say
is that
if two people are in a car and you're
both out committing crimes right you're
both responsible you're both responsible
there's something called the felony
murder rule
and the felony murder rule is that if
you're in the commission of a crime and
somebody dies so if you and i went and
robbed the bank
and i go in and start
you know shooting up the tellers and
kill two tellers you're responsible for
the murder also
so the theory of robert's prosecution
was that they were friends they were on
this crime spree together
and that even though he was convicted of
the murder
um
you know
he was still responsible and guilty of
murder it's no different than the james
daley case which i've talked about
before
they convicted one guy jack piercy and
then they tried my client after that
one guy got sentenced to life one guy
got sentenced to death it's crazy they
don't have to have any evidence
whatsoever that you're even friends with
that guy right right it had his word
right isn't his word enough and and the
the piece of evidence another article
evidence that we're held is a report
that uh
that
when he made a statement
like the money on my trial as i said
that
i didn't have anything to do with the
murder he never knew me and different
things of that nature
uh and they withheld that and it and it
would held that
and that was so important to change the
outcome of my trial because
they went they took me to trial on the
theory that he was friends and that i
knew him and i had a connection to him
through the car
but had i would have had that piece of
information
the the interject in my trial i would
have never probably got found guilty to
that extent and they also would help
various different um uh
uh
statements and evidence as it relates to
the witnesses
that was very inconsistent that was very
favorable to me
and that could have actually printed
back to the to the guy who was actually
uh
convicted of the murder
and attached to all those other spree of
crimes
um
yeah so
it just was a a lot of stuff man that
they would held that
that almost made it impossible
um
for me to unravel
and to uh to obtain my freedom and you
know i'd like to say that that's
uncommon too but it's not so in other
words when
prosecutors are working on one theory
full steam ahead right
and
they then are met
with you might be wrong we might have
been wrong all along
the instinct
99 times out of 100
is to plow ahead and rationalize
why the true perpetrator in robert's
case
why did he all of a sudden say robert
had nothing to do with it
oh well maybe he
is making this up because he feels
guilty that he implicated his friend who
really wasn't his friend i have in
clementia geary's case which we've
talked about in your listeners know
about
the true killer confessed she confessed
over and over again to friends to
neighbors drunk not drunk to police
in denying him post-conviction relief
now this is a judge
the judge chalked it up a survivor's
guilt
so in other words whether it's a
prosecutor's judges they'll make an
excuse to protect the prosecution
because it's all about winning or losing
let's talk about that what is that is
that human nature is it like
do people just want to confirm their
initial suspicions
and they rationalize all sorts of
reasons
why
what they initially thought was right
and this new evidence that shows that
it's not right is wrong like what what
is it is it they don't they don't just
don't want to be
they don't want to lose i think it's a
fundamental flaw
that we have as human beings that i
share as a taurus i especially share it
how dare you bring up astrology
[Laughter]
but but i um
i'm stubborn but i think as i see this
time and time again and watching juries
deliberate because i do mock trials and
focus groups or speaking to people
post-verdict but you can apply it
to politics
i think of one fundamental flaw we have
as mammals is our inability to be
flexible in our reasoning
and i think that once we make a decision
about something
it's very very
difficult to get people to reconsider i
see that in really intelligent people
too and it's makes me sad it's maddening
it drives me crazy yeah because it's
like
you aren't the the part of the problem i
think with police
with prosecutors with the whole legal
system is that
it becomes
a game and i don't mean a game like it's
a joke i mean a game like you're trying
to win yes and whenever someone is
involved in something where they're
trying to win
they do whatever the [ __ ] they can
people cheat they move golf balls right
they they do whatever the [ __ ] they can
don't look at jamie
whatever i hear people moving those
[ __ ] things whenever i hear that you
do
right here golf ball well people cheat
man they they find ways to pretend that
they didn't do something when they did
it they find ways to justify the things
they did do
they find ways to
pass the buck and put it on if if they
can score that w right and you see cops
do it they they plant evidence on
someone they think was probably guilty
but they don't have enough evidence on
them they find rationalizations
and it's because
there's a game going on it's a win or
lose and it becomes a real problem and
not only that with a lot of cops
this quotas like you literally have to
arrest a certain amount of people right
which is insanity like what the [ __ ] did
they do if no one commits a crime what
do they do if no one speeds if you have
a quota where you have to arrest a
hundred people for speeding what the
[ __ ] do you do if everybody makes an
agreement we all get on facebook and we
say hey
let everybody drive the [ __ ] speed
limit for the next 60 days and let's
crush the legal system because these
cops have to they have to make a certain
amount of pullovers they have to pull a
certain amount of people over and write
a certain amount of tickets they have
quotas if you don't meet those quotas
they get in trouble so what the [ __ ]
kind of game is that right i i would say
a lot a lot of that a lot of
just like we have structural racism
right
and with when i say structural race i
mean like institutional
uh uh things that set up through uh
regulation rules and policies like
redlining right uh
and you just have like uh
flawlessness in a variety of different
systems they got people that work for
company they got a lot of
flawlessness and they don't really they
don't really understand that you're
employed in the system
that that treat people unfair calls
people home and you can't even see it
and some people can be a part of a
system of part of a program or part of
an organization
that
uh
have that win mentality
right that win women by all-cause
mentality
and
they lose their empathy for people right
and and when people lose their empathy
when you know we did find those things
and a lot of people don't like uh
they hear hillary this type of [ __ ]
but when you lose your empathy for
people
you become technically a social path
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify